hey guys in this video we're gonna talk
about nine reasons why you should
consume black garlic okay what is black
garlic basically an slightly heated and
aged garlic its fermented okay they
heated it 170 degrees Fahrenheit for 30
days okay now the purpose of doing this
is to several fold one is to take the
intensity out of that strong pungent
sulfur smell as well as the taste it's
kind of hard to consume raw garlic so
when you ferment it you increase the
bioavailability of nutrients but you
also decrease the intensity of certain
factors that make it easier to consume
and the texture is completely different
and the taste is completely different
but the benefits of this garlic it'll
decrease pathogens like decrease viruses
in the body the bacteria funguses
candide up all these unfriendly guys
number two it decreases inflammatory
conditions if you have arthritis or just
inflammation in general in your colon
it's really good for leaky gut it
decreases insulin resistance
significantly so it's great for
diabetics it will improve your immune
system in your immune systems ability to
fight off infection number five
nutrient-rich vitamins minerals and
phytonutrients and number six this is a
real key point it increases the
bioavailability of nutrients so the
absorption of nutrients you will consume
more nutrients when it's fermented than
if it's raw because there are certain
things in raw garlic that prevent the
full absorption of these nutrients
number seven phytonutrients okay number
eight decrease risk of cancer
significantly number nine decreased risk
of cardiovascular problems like heart
problems plaquing clotting stroke high
blood pressure so go ahead and try this
out and tell me what you think hey I
appreciate your attention and if you're
enjoying these videos go ahead and
subscribe and I will definitely keep you
updated on future events live events and
webinars that we're going to do very
soon